Switching topics though off of Donald Trump,
let's get into something a little more meaningful,
right?
Well, according to New Poles, 70% of Republican
voters here in the United States, vast majority,
70% actually support the idea put forward
last week by Senator Bernie Sanders and representative
Alexandria Kazuyo to cap interest rates for
credit cards and payday lenders.
At fifth teen percent, 70% of Republicans
love this idea put forward by these democratic
socialists.
The reason I love this story is because right
now you have certain Democratic presidential
candidates named Joe Biden who are telling
us that we can't move too far to the left,
that you're gonna scare off the moderate Republicans.
You're not going to get any republicans to
your side pushing these far left crazy anti
corporate ideas.
That's what the establishment tells us.
That's what the conventional wisdom in DC
tries to tell us.
But it turns out that time after time in poll
after poll, Republicans actually really love
the socialist ideas and it's not just the
capping of the credit card interest rates,
which as of last week, we're at a almost 22%
average.
People with good credit are still paying more
than 15% on credit cards.
People with very poor or no credit who have
to go to payday lenders.
You're talking about dozens upon dozens of
percentage points in interest.
I mean 30 40 50 or more in interest on those
just because they had no credit.
They get trapped in these endless debt cycles
for this $9 billion industry.
In fact, that $9 billion they make has only
off the interest each year and they're doing
better than ever because Trump has gutted
the CFPB and now they're not regulating these
people like they had been towards the end
of the Obama administration.
So they're back.
The predatory payday lenders are back and
they're screwing over American citizens, and
70% of Republicans understand that just like
70% of Republicans understand that credit
card companies are doing the exact same thing.
But it's not just capping the interest rates
here.
They support Medicare for all.
They support a $15 minimum wage.
They support getting money out of politics
and overturning citizens United.
They support taking action on climate change.
They support renewable energy, they support
debt free or free college.
They support all of these things that have
been trashed as far left socialist ideas.
Now to throw a wrench in the works, there's
another pole from Gallup that says that only
40% of Americans say that socialism would
be good for the United States.
51% say that it would be bad, but the flaw
with this Gallup poll is that it's straight
up just asking people what socialism be a
good thing or a bad thing for the United States.
Once you start breaking that down into individual
policies, that might be socialism, but if
you just say, Hey, what about Medicare for
all?
Do you that guess what?
Overwhelming majority of everybody says, yes,
I do.
I think that's a good idea.
Even if you mention afterwards that well,
isn't that kind of socialism?
They'll say, oh, well, I guess it is, but
I like it.
Same thing with social security, which also,
by the way, a majority of all parties support
expanding social security.
We, we have socialism in place in the United
States today already.
So this Gallup poll that says only 40% think
it would be a good thing.
Yeah.
When you ask a misleading question, when you
ask about a word, which is socialism, that
most people, honest to God, couldn't even
define, then yeah, they're probably going
to say it's bad.
But once you start breaking it down into individual
policies, once you divorce those policies
from a politician or political party, support
for them goes up.
Other polls have proven that when you attach
it to a political party, the support does
drop a little, not a ton, but it does drop
a little, but it shows you that the American
public is hungry for policy, and more importantly,
they're hungry for policies that most Republicans
and even some
centrist Democrats would absolutely classify
as socially.
We have to take a quick break.
We'll be right back with more on the David
Pakman show